we have the story from the Babylon B
check this out Elon Musk vows to reveal
government and media collusion once he
figures out where these red dots are
coming from and it's a bunch of lasers
pointed all over his body so Elon Musk
uh I guess he released this information
to Matt taibi there's a lot to go
through a lot a lot to go through and
the first handful of tweets were so
boring and I was like okay I'm out like
it's like exposition of hey you know
there was censorship inclusion and we're
like yeah yeah we know that and so uh
but finally I think around tweet number
eight Matt taibi started to drop hard
documents what this shows is that
Democrats had a strong direct line to
Twitter to remove content that they felt
should be removed let's just put it that
way it benefited them they targeted
people like real James Woods Now Matt
Tybee says both parties had access to
these tools however
he was going to say the system wasn't
balanced it was based on context because
Twitter uh was and is overwhelmingly
staffed by people of one political
orientation there were more channels
more ways to complain open to the left
well Democrats than the right
he says the resulting slant in content
moderation decisions is visible in the
documents you're about to read however
it's also the assessment of multiple
current and former high-level executives
So currently he's releasing a lot of
really interesting stuff how about this
one White House spokesman Kaylee mcenany
was locked out of her account for
tweeting about the hunter Biden laptop
story prompting a furious letter from
Trump campaign staffer Mike Han who see
that least pretend to care for the next
20 days
this led public policy executive Carolyn
storm to send out a polite WTF query
several employees noted there was
tension between the comms and policy
teams who had little and less control
over moderation and the safety and Trust
teams I think the the one of the big
things here was that you have this
this is a
let me just read the Tweet you can see
the confusion in the following lengthy
exchange which ends up including Vegeta
and former trust and safety Chief Joel
Roth com's official Trenton Kennedy
writes I'm struggling to understand the
policy basis for marking this as unsafe
but at this point everyone knew this was
F said one former employee but the
response was essentially to air on the
side of continuing to air so we'll go
through this I'm not just going to track
every single tweet I want to get your
guys's thoughts on what you've seen so
far as and then we'll bring up tweets as
we go evidence of direct uh collusion
what do you think I think it's the least
surprising thing in the world now I'm
glad we get to see the actual documents
I mean I'm glad I'm glad it's not just
us assuming things because you're you're
looking at actual emails here but is
anyone shocked tonight is it is anyone
shocked to figure out that Twitter is
staffed by a bunch of commies and that
Twitter will censor out people with
voices on the right and that Twitter has
a direct line to people in the White
House this is how it's worked for a long
time of of this is why people don't
worry about re-election when you're in
the Democratic party because you jump
right from the Joe Biden Administration
you go work for Twitter or you go work
for CNN or you go it's all just what
what's that what's that George Carlin
saying it's all one club and we're not
in it yeah that's what it is it's not
surprising at all half these people are
probably gonna go work for Joe Biden
next week that's right well it's very
interesting because obviously Democrats
had more connections to Twitter Twitter
obviously had a lot of employees there
that were also donating a lot of money
to the DNC but it was according to these
leaks both parties that had access to
these tools tools and both parties
including the Donald Trump
Administration and His White House had
requested certain individuals be banned
and their requests were granted now a
couple days ago The Intercept launched a
story about how the DHS was uh going
around and banning people on Big Tech
social media predominantly because of a
law passed by Donald Trump so what was
Donald Trump's involvement here did he
create the tools I mean obviously he
passed a law with the DHS according to
the intercept that allowed all of this
to happen from the very beginning but
did he set up the tools that entrapped
him and hurt him eventually I think
that's worth asking today especially
with number 10 the revealed that Matt
taibi talked about and I think it's
worth considering the larger
implications of it okay what do you guys
think I get the vibe that these people
are using like an ends justify the means
mentality where
you know I have a friend a really good
friend like my first friend that I ever
knew uh we've been friends 45 years 43
years and he uh was like sometimes you
know you just have to punch he was like
the punch a Nazi mindset I don't
remember exactly the way he worded him
he's like sometimes you got to use
violence to stop evil I'm like no dude
then you become the evil that's not the
way to do it he's like sometimes you
need to use dishonest tactics to be evil
and I'm like that is not the path that
that makes you evil and uh maybe he's
right because George Washington
dishonest so just confusion in his
enemies won the war so there's an
argument I see but we're not at War in
the United States we're all civilians
living in normal life you're not
supposed to like
ban people because you're afraid that
your political opponent that's my
opinion I think that what they did was
evil and they thought that it would just
the the ends of making sure Trump didn't
get into the White House was would
justify it but they are at War I mean
this is this is something that I've
certainly come around to in recent years
you're not and I'm glad you're not and
I'm not I'm glad you're not that type of
person but they are we we make this
mistake or at least I I shouldn't say I
shouldn't lump it everyone we make this
mistake on the right all the time of we
we asset we take our values and we put
them on the Communists well I we I
wouldn't go too far well I wouldn't say
this or I wouldn't say that I wouldn't
just lie to get through this we're
constantly taking our values and
projecting them onto people who do not
share our values they would in their
minds right or wrong and they're
obviously wrong but right or wrong in
their minds they are at war with an evil
racist misogynistic United States of
America that deserves to be brought to
its knees now we can call him nut jobs
and they are but we have to acknowledge
whether or not we are they are at War
and they act like they're at War it
would never occur to one of these
commies to have possession of Twitter
and have the ability to stop us and not
use it that that's how the right things
well I should abstain from using power
they don't think that way at all they
use power when they get it some
high-profile uh lapis personalities
actually said this when it was announced
that Elon was going to buy the platform
earlier in the year they started we
started seeing all of these people say
oh no now we're going to get banned he's
going to come for us and there was one
Twitter exchange with a prominent
leftist where they were like Elon is
trying to restore people why would you
think that he's going to censor you you
and then someone said something like
it's because they're projecting and
someone said exactly because we know how
power is wielded so you basically had
these conversations among prominent
leftists where they were like
we expect the right to come after us and
censor us because that's exactly what we
do and that's how you use power and
people on the right are are uh I say
write Loosely because it's like
Libertarians moderates former liberals
keep doing this thing like I'll give you
an example Rick Santorum comes on the
show glad to have him and he said we
can't impeach Joe Biden we we have to
play by the rules we can't and it's like
Joe Biden is suspected of very serious
crimes and Corruption and you're saying
we shouldn't do it we shouldn't do it
because we don't want to stoop to their
level and if only one side is actively
engaged well then only one side is
actually going to win but here's the
best part they say the exact same thing
about what we talk about they say the
there's a culture War happening and the
writer the only ones fighting it
meanwhile Republicans have no agenda
they're sitting on their hands and even
if they do take Congress they're taking
Congress now we're likely going to see
very little done oh we'll see nothing
done actually no I take that back that's
not fair sorry Logan no no no go ahead
go ahead no no we'll see plenty you're
done it'll still be more of the left
because of the absolute Unix we have
that run the Republican party it is the
low T GOP they'll work with they'll work
with the Democrats for two years and
they'll brag that they're spending a
little bit less you know what we're not
being as radical as they are but still
will only go left because like I said we
have this nutless party that's supposed
to represent us and they don't actually
represent anybody except themselves in
their lobbyists in Washington DC normal
working people who just want to be left
alone have virtually no representation
I just want to make a quick Point here
because you're right on the money when
you said Low T GOP but I also see it as
the GOP also setting up the
infrastructure which will be later down
the line used against them if you
remember after uh 9 11 the GOP set up a
National Security State which now is
turning inwards instead of outwards and
is looking at the people who set them up
at the political party who set them up
as enemies of the state punishing them
censoring them not allowing them to
organize not allowing them to do
anything and have any kind of
significance when it comes to Future
political power so the GOP even though
they're Low T they do deserve to be
criticized for setting up the DHS for
censoring people they they do they
should be criticized for setting up this
National Security State which is used
against the people I want to give you
guys an example uh and and it probably
acquires a lot of examples so you can
understand the difference when uh you
get like a right-wing group say the
proud boys marching through Portland the
right will say nothing in their defense
like I mean like prominent politicians
and things like that in fact they'll
probably be like we reject white
supremacy Donald Trump stand back and
stand by which is a wacky nonsensical
statement
when
far leftists across the country
started burning down buildings and quite
literally killing people in the Summer
of Love
Joe Biden's campaign and Kamala Harris
herself solicited donations to bail
these people out that's an easy easy
example of the asymmetrical culture War
the right will be like hey look you know
we're we're not a fan of what's going on
here we condemn it because it's wrong
and the left will be like we can say
that whenever we want we can criticize
you for your bad actions but we're going
to give money to our Bad actors and
there's nothing you can do I'll give you
another example
when uh January was it January 20th 2017
when far left extremists antifa went
around smashing windows and burning uh
setting a car on fire in Washington DC
and then there was a mass arrest they
actually sued the city of DC and Won
antifa Won I think like a million plus
or some ridiculous number and most of
their charges were dropped that's
asymmetrical well it was Mao who said
all political power comes from the
barrel of a gun yeah these people it is
if you were to pull the average American
not just left or right but just to go
find 10 people in the mall somewhere and
ask them who commits political acts of
violence most of those people would say
the right and I want to make sure I give
them credit because they chronicled it I
didn't Breitbart actually listed all 395
incidents of assault and murder against
Trump supporters during Trump's four
years in office it's a laundry list of
people getting shot in the head Molotov
cocktail it is it is nasty yet people
don't know about this why don't they
know about it because the people who
bring us the news in this country I know
people think think this is too harsh
they actually want to see you hurt they
do it's not it's not that they're
ignoring it they're not biased they're
not liberal they're not to the left no
no they are actually your mortal enemy
and if you were to get shot in the face
for what you believe crossing the street
tonight not a single one of them would
shed a tear they wouldn't even report on
it because they'd be thrilled about it
they would report on it what's the old
saying do you know
if it bleeds it leaves yeah yeah and so
what they would do is is they would uh
well to be fair though they would write
articles saying that they were asking
for it they would say like you know
Mutual conflict my my favorite article
uh pertaining to this goes back to the
529 Insurrection at the White House
where NBC wrote uh what is it they said
they said um St John's Church that set
fire after peaceful protest becomes
destructive or something to that effect
instead of saying violent extremists
tore down barricades at White House
injuring law enforcement officers and
setting fire to building they said
peaceful protest turns destructive I I
use the example a lot that we are
sandwiched and when I say we I'm just
talking about normal people not not not
just people in this room who are highly
informed normal people friends of yours
we are sandwiched and people don't
realize it because what's happened is
you mentioned the people who got out
without charges there's some Kami hag in
New York City I forget her name Molotov
cocktail and NYPD cop car and I believe
she just got 18 months I think she could
have got 20 30 years slap on the wrist
and she's gone what happens is they own
every institution now from the doj on
down and they also own most of the vile
mentally ill Street scum at the bottom
who's more than willing to commit acts
of Terror so Joe Biden will get up
behind the podium and he'll call you a
threat to democracy you'll end the
Republic of Nazi white supremacist the
vile Street scum understand that they
have nothing to live for and they
understand those are marching orders and
they also understand if they were to do
something that the people on the top
will run a protection racket for them in
the bottom and so who's screwed we're
screwed the normal people in the middle
who don't have any protection thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time